okay hello everyone welcome to a wolf
language design review part of our
incremental language development series
it looks like we've only got two items
on the agenda but I know that these
items are going to have lots of
complicated stuff underneath them
so this is an item from one of our older
design documents where I think we'd
classified this as a design Chestnut but
the idea of
should we and if so how would we hook
interpreter into pattern matching on the
left hand side
of a function that's complicated yeah
this is even a good idea right so I
would say probably not yeah I mean I
think we'd probably all be in general
agreement we don't want calls to the
pattern matcher to be taking multiple
seconds because we have to parse
something on Alpha so we'd have to well
that's hopefully changing because we're
hopefully getting local Alpha pausing
for most of this stuff I don't know what
the status of that project is and I'd
like to hear about that if somebody
could talk that off
go ahead well I was just gonna say I
mean it also seems like
right I mean normally with interpreters
and like API functions and form
functions and so on there's a single
sort of type signature quotes
right like you there's no like uh
did it match a city oh it didn't match a
city then if it's not a city it must be
a string the string is more General than
City or something like that
right it seems like it makes more sense
makes less sense to Define it like in
actual down values it would make sense
to have an object like an API function
that's sort of like a callable function
with a single type signature which you
could use but I think we might already
have that
what are you suggesting
I I I'm just saying that I think
with patterns the whole point is that
you can actually tell you know which is
more specific Which is less specific you
have an idea that matches or it doesn't
with interpreters we don't usually do
that it's usually just you declare this
must be a city if it isn't you're gonna
fail there's no match or not match it's
just it's just you it has a single type
that it's targeting but wait wait a
second what is that I I mean this is
going in a kind of a direction that I
was thinking about and it's the I mean
if you if I mean you can look at it as
um form function API function work with
types not with patterns but it's not
true I mean in interpret does support
some types
okay listen listen let's cut let's cut
this short for a second okay we've got
the following syntax we've got things
like X colon blank right that matches
blank matches any expression blank
integer matches any expression integer
we all know this
so the question is does it make any
sense to have what you wrote whoever
wrote up at the top there something like
this
right that is that could make sense
I think it does make sense to have some
some situation where you say I want to
match types
just tell me whether why this doesn't
make sense because
yeah what what is X bound to this bound
to a string that contains a number is
bound to the number
is that's going to be the string New
York or is it going to be the entity New
York right so let's do that so so then
the question is when we say F of quotes
New York what does it do that's really
the question we're asking
right what would no the question is what
is X bound to because by anything
X is bound to the string in New York but
that's right I agree I agree I agree
so that as such Doesn't make a lot of
sense
the more useful thing is to have
something and again I think maybe you
can already do this with like API
function or something like that where
you essentially Define you get an object
where it expects that this argument I'm
going to take a city and this argument
I'm going to take a number and so on and
then it runs a function on it
right I mean if I do this for example
and um
I do this and I say apply this to
X
Arrow NYC
right
so unbelievably slow
I was unbelievably slow okay so can
somebody send this to the speed alias
the thing is that probably the I don't
want to know actually we're loading a
bunch of parts I don't want to know a
theory I want somebody to look at it I
want somebody to fix it well what
happens if we evaluate it again yeah
okay we can try that
that's as far as we're gonna go okay
Works nice and quickly so let's find out
why we had to why it was so slow and
let's fix it
okay but out of curiosity if you well
actually you shouldn't do I was gonna
say if you if you like turned off your
internet and then ran it again would it
work is it cached locally but you can't
do that I can't do that the um
well you can block
okay let's not go though we don't let's
not waste time on that okay the the
there's a problem in loading packages
here we should fix it right so but the
main point here is that this is a
mechanism by which we can do what we
want it's a little bit messy because
it's got all of these all of this all of
this stuff about apis and so on in it
so the question really I think is
is there I mean
this reminds me a bit of options pattern
I've never found that mechanism that
wonderful
right so you know
things like this
where where now we can say then this
goes to something with option value
I'm making sense it seems like a similar
mechanism
yeah but it seems to me that what you're
really interested here is The
Interpreter type system rather than the
fact that you're turning a string into
an object
like I I don't think that the main event
what we what we're interested in is the
fact that we're matching you're right
we're interested in
you know we're matching an entity but we
can do that we can say you know X colon
entity and not that people do this very
much entity City triple blank
right
that's kind of goofy because you could
have what if it's wrapped in data or
something like that I mean it's writing
a pattern like that it's it's it's
brittle okay you want to have a function
but the way to do it we would have some
kind of you know entity queue and you
know entity
then you have a number queue then you
have a string queue wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait so the things that
we could do here are you're saying if I
have something like location which can
match multiple things I want to know do
I have an expression okay so the issue
is do I have an expression that could
represent a location is that correct not
the interpretable thing not the string
but an expression that is the possible
output from a location interpreter is
that correct
and I think the inter the location
interpreter takes kind of whatever in
terms of entity and always returns a
dual position or something
okay I'm asking the following question
what we want for our pattern matcher is
something which matches Expressions not
strings correct are we are we
interpreters don't need to take strings
I thought they could take other things
too that is true but what we're
interested in here is not the
transforming of string into things is
the transforming of types into patterns
okay can we stay okay
let's try this is this going to work yes
that worked right so the use cases I
think okay if I understand the use case
it is I have a function that can take
any kind of you know geoposition
specification whatever it might be how
do I write that pattern yes
right and and the point being which
color is I think correctly making that
we have essentially a it's not really a
fuzzy type system in The Interpreter
world that is things that can represent
a location
as the location thing right
yes and no because The Interpreter hype
system is designed also around the fact
that we are taking strings and
transforming okay and I understand that
but the point that we're making here is
we are interested in something that can
take an expression representing a
location
is that correct
yes that is correct what I'm saying this
interpreter type system exactly that's
what we need to know
we want something which can match any
expression that represents a location is
that correct
and ideally also you know
any that that has one not the sense one
okay fair enough fair enough
so in other words this might be you know
the Battle of Hastings or something
and we we should be able to say f of
this and then what we want to be able to
do is that on the right hand side so we
will have defined F so that on the right
hand side it can say geo-distance
well I shouldn't say this that it's it's
going to be
okay let's say here is geo-distance
X comma here or something
that makes sense that's the kind of
thing we want to be able to write yeah
but the the the thing I was afraid to
say before is that the problem with
location is that the location
interpreter is very special because it
always returns a geoposition so if you
get something that has a location like I
I understand I understand what you're
saying I understand what you're saying
it takes a certain set of things every
one of these interpreters takes a
certain set of things as input right
there are other things that there's two
functions that interpreter performs
function number one you know accept or
reject
function number two transformed to a
canonical form am I right
yes I'm right so what I'm saying is what
what we care about here is the accept or
reject function not the transmission
technology you're writing that it does
do the both those things but you're
wrong because I'm sure it's implemented
yeah it's going to be doubling the work
and doubling the time if it's running on
some more from alpha server if you uh do
those things okay fine fine but I'm just
trying to understand conceptually what
we're trying to achieve can I just say
something about that quickly I think
that if we want to Define this cleanly
and not have 15 incompatible hype
systems each other
we cannot say that location I mean if if
you if we're gonna call this location
then it's a geoposition
then it can do what you're saying here
but but I think that if you don't know
if you define it inter in terms of
interpreter types then what you want is
that interpreter of that thing returns
exactly that thing
and not a failure but if it transforms
it then it's not in the type really I'm
sorry I don't understand what you're
saying I think the argument is to tell
me if this is correct Carlo so the
problem is that you don't like the idea
that interpreter of low you know
representing location would match the
string NYC because even though it could
be transformed to a geoposition it's a
string NYC it's not itself really truly
representing a geoposition
yes okay but we I understood that point
how did you take him in that will also
get transformed to a geoposition yes we
know yes I understand I understand okay
the the okay so maybe I said something
wrong previously that let's take this
example right what can be accepted by
the by the location interpreter
right so you're saying one of the things
that can be accepted is the string NYC
which is something we do not want to
match in this case
right no I think yeah we don't want to
match we don't want it to match that's
the point
right maybe I don't know that we
necessarily don't want it to match I
mean if you have Geo marker of quotes
NYC it should probably fail but yeah
but this is this is going to be my main
complaint about this and why I argue
this is better served by having lots of
you know specially designed you know Q
functions or something would be that
that as we had the discussion with like
dates like a little bit ago a week ago
or something there's going to be cases
where it's like interpreter date of you
know Galileo
and it's like what do you do there
yes I understand we're at some would
arbitrary but but let's let's try to
understand the problem we're trying to
solve here the problem we're trying to
solve is we're trying to write a
function that will accept
as an argument any reasonable thing that
represents a location
now the question is what does it pass to
its body when it does that
does it pass to its body a thing which
has been digested and turned into a
geodes geoposition or does it pass to
its body
okay there are three things that could
pass
okay thing number one
undigested input
I.E whatever was said to
be able to correspond to a location
okay thing number two
um
let's see thing number three is fully
digested
canonicalized transformed input
I.E in this particular case
EG geoposition
that sounds extremely inconsistent with
pattern matching with everything else I
know I know so we're most useful but the
most inconsistent okay so let's look at
what what okay so the intermediate case
I'm sorry what's the intermediate case
can we fill that in please before you go
into a different topic and I think
you're not describing the right thing
here when we designed interpreter there
are two steps to interpreter one step is
the interpretation and that's the thing
that turns the string or an entity I'm
well aware into something then there is
the Restriction function which is what
you're describing here so for example
not what I'm describing here it's not
what I'm describing yeah let me finish
restricted is the thing that says I
don't want to accept any integer that's
what I'm describing here it's not what
I'm describing yeah yeah and I'm telling
you you you're you're off the point
where we should be talking about so
what's the relationship between
interpreter types restrictions Etc and
pattern matching it's not we don't care
about the parsing here
I mean I feel like restricted I mean
right I mean restricted when you when
you say I have a number and it's
restricted to this or I have a city and
it's restricted to being population
greater than a million you know that's
there's an implicit restriction that it
be interpreted interpretable as a city
too right
let's zoom out again for a second what's
actually useful okay stop talking about
the implementation of interpreter or any
of that stuff I want to talk about
what's useful we're not talking about
how it's implemented we're not talking
about how we you know connect it to
interpreter we're just talking about
what's useful right the thing that you
want and it's a thing that's not
specific at all to interpreter stuff is
is the problem of of basically
checking and canonicalizing inputs to
functions it's extremely common that you
know that you write a function body and
you make assumptions that oh I'm going
to have a geoposition it's not going to
be a Geo position x y z or Geo position
enu and it's going to be all nice and
and so on and and you want to be able to
somehow check that in the arguments and
have it be canonicalized in the body
right because the body is going to
correctly handle all the different forms
it's merely that you want to pass all
those forms through regardless of
whether they are geoposition you know
enu or something else right yes
and the problem is that this is very
inconsistent with how pattern matching
works right now right so let's let's
before we start before we go anywhere
else let's look at that issue right that
issue let's take I mean in in some of
these things let's take something some
of these it just isn't relevant it's
just a lot of this stuff
is
yeah okay so
um sorry of these three cases I think I
would choose the intermediate case to
avoid
repeating work
and
yeah for example in this case it would
be entities but if if I pass a country I
don't want it to be converted into a
into a Geo position
I think the intermediate case is the
clearly
hard to follow number one makes the most
sense to me
right but if it's a do interpreter of
location of 30 Years War
yeah
right so you know what what does that
even mean and which of right suppose
that's three I I what would two be in in
this case entity of oh yeah in this case
that would be
it will be this I feel like this is the
different you know this is a different
problem right I mean this is a problem
but it's like we already have a way
where you could say you know Geo marker
of 30 Years War and it will it will mark
this spot and maybe that's that's silly
but we do generally speaking assign
positions to these sorts of things so if
you want to function that has all the
same behaviors Geo marker and everything
like that then it should handle a 30
Years War like so these These are the
three cases one two three this is
undigested entified and interpreted and
digested and in a lot of cases two and
three are going to be the same but the
thing is the thing I don't understand
about this is like what is the input to
the function in in these three cases
does this pattern also transform things
or not
okay we have the question we haven't
defined it right right could interpret a
pattern except more than one binding so
kind of like how pattern just takes one
symbol as the first argument could
interpret a pattern
optionally take more representing the
different states so you can use them in
your function body
no I don't think it should
you reject that idea before you reject
that idea let's think about it for a
second okay so the idea is you'd have
you have one variable that's bound to
the the undigested and one variable
that's bound to the digestive yeah and
then you can use
both if you wanted to in in your
function body or replacement rule or
whatever or instead of having multiple
symbols we could have like interpreter
value which is like option value yes
which pulls it out
well I kind of like the two symbols
because it's just it's yeah the syntax
will be the syntax would be true and you
can use condition and stuff like that
let's take a look at what this would
mean okay
so let's say we say this okay
and let's just imagine let's imagine to
begin with that we bind it to a single
thing X I think we wouldn't even I would
do that because this is using pattern
I think the X would actually belong to
interpret a pattern in there we would
probably want a nice input form similar
to pattern but that would be the thing
that it's binding and then you can add
extra symbols in there to represent the
other states
right right so pattern pattern takes a
symbol to bind to and it takes a pattern
on the right hand side this takes a
symbol to bind to an interpreter type on
the right hand side and maybe it takes a
second pattern to bind to to that it
will use to bind to the canonicalized
value just as a list or okay I don't
know something like that and if you do
have something on the outside you know X
colon on the outside then that would
just be the original on undigested and
bind to the under so it's okay so hold
on so then what this corresponds to in
our three digestion levels right if I
said
um you know U colon that's the
undigested thing
but that's how I get number one well
actually we wouldn't even need multiple
bindings because that that one there
that is already the undigested one so we
really only need one and interpreter
pattern right for the well I don't
understand how do you get both the both
numbers two and three
bye-bye doing what you just I'm sorry no
you're on the outside I was right
skipping two though so yeah I was
thinking of just one and three as being
the main things yeah right so so in this
case
what this would do then is on the right
hand side
so
this would I mean I don't know how this
would work but this would
be feeding to a thing that is some kind
of uh you know interpreter test
you know is this interpretable as a
location the thing that's been fed in so
for example that could be
you know
four North six East or something
presumably
that could be that would be a valid
thing that would match this thing here
is that correct
yeah if I say if I say cases of some
list here comma interpreter pattern
of location
that would work
yeah
and then if you wanted the actual
interpreted values that would be the
thing that you bind inside interpretive
pattern right right so then if I wanted
this
I would say that colon greater than you
know Geo distance whatever it is
right with an underscore
was there an underscore on the left
under X on the X on the left right has
to be a pattern
yeah no
it would just be a symbol like that yeah
that's the pattern I see I see I see oh
oh neat oh yeah
okay now one one thing is I think this
function will be much much much more
useful if it were not specific to
interpreter
like if we had a top level function that
was like uh I don't know I mean for
example geoposition right if you apply
geoposition to any of the different
geoposition-like objects it will
canonicalize it to a geoposition so how
would you use that as sort of a
canonicalized binding or something like
that
here
well okay so hold on I mean let's
imagine it was called pattern category
and
it was
you know mostly it supported interpreter
names but it could have additional ones
and there might be interpreter names
that didn't support
I I'm just afraid The Interpreter names
are going to be a toy because they're
gonna have to call out to a server well
most of them increasingly won't have to
well certainly if you want the resolved
thing they'll have to right
right and also by the way the well you
know users can't Define interpreters but
you know in my like code I write I
constantly am defining these sort of
canonicalizing functions
I see where you know the first thing I
do in my function is I I say try and
canonicalize my arguments if you fail
the whole thing fails otherwise continue
okay so that that's a that's a pattern
where
you know okay so the pattern that you're
defining is
test if it is
canonicalizable
and then you know feed through the
canonicalized form
right
which is very similar to what we just
said with interpreter pattern except
that that one is specific to
interpreters
right and the way I see it is it's it's
it's it's it's obvious how you would do
this except for the fact that you need
to be able to do deal with a case where
it doesn't match that makes sense okay
if this said
and how does this relate to the option
about I mean
the question is could we have a thing
that
I mean let this is a bad name but
canonicalizing pattern yeah
of
let's say function here
I assume you'll be a symbol first
either be X comma the function like with
The Interpreter case yeah okay okay fine
so let's actually say y comma function
because we could have an X okay x x
would be the outer thing yes would be
the UN canonicalized form okay so
canonicalizing pattern of this
would be such that it tries to apply
this function
right so here's this is the complication
so so okay in the body you'll have it
it'll be true that that f of x is equal
to Y right
like that or fun of X will equal y the
problem is right exactly the test to
test that the f of x actually returns
something meaningful well okay so here's
a possibility
so
I make a default to doing the same thing
that basically confirmed us of looking
for like failures and missing and stuff
right the default can test can be
failure queue yeah well but but there's
a difference does it that's even a
simpler thing canonicalizing pattern
okay canonicalizing pattern and it could
be y comma fun comma
okay let's say this is just geoposition
and then this says underscore
geoposition
right Imagining the geoposition return
to failure object could have failed
which I don't think it does but yeah
well but it doesn't return a Geo
position I think it fails well I think
no I bet it will but it will return on
evaluated
I see right I see I I agree that having
it as a pattern there could be useful
but I think it's more useful as a
function both because match the operator
form of match Q is so easy
and and the underscore question mark
parentheses is so ugly yeah yeah right
okay but okay so but what will be the
function here that would test whether it
was actually
there would have to be a geoposition
queue or something
yeah
sorry the operator match Q like
Christopher was saying would be oh well
it's not going to do it for you because
as we can see a job as well for geopolis
yeah yeah so what what is the test in
the case of Geo position
there is a GIS backtake geolocation
queue that tests all the videos Geo
functions right but now the question is
it typically promoted but but
sorry go ahead
you know I I was just commenting on the
assistance of that function and that we
could consider promoting it to systems
we have a similar thing with day two
with we have internal possible date
queue because there's lots of things
that may be dates you know a number can
be a date but
it's context dependent how you want to
handle certain things
but now okay for this test though which
direction is it is it true when it
passes or is it true and it fails
right like would you have failure queue
there as the default or not a failure
queue I think I think it's true when it
passes
which is already what we have for the
second argument of interpreter
okay
but I mean let's just understand whether
this assume we could make this function
thing work
and possibly
omitting that it would have some default
right so by the way to do The
Interpreter pattern all you would do is
instead of writing geoposition you'd
write interpreter of quotes location
right and and if I remember right if it
doesn't match it'll be a failure object
it'll fail by default because it's
beautiful
in this case here
yeah and you don't need the fun you
don't need the fun because the default
Behavior will be correct
right and then you could probably align
that to just say quotes location
Maybe
I'm a little a little nervous about that
but yeah
okay so then this would be I mean this
is interesting
this would then pass
well I think this is interesting I mean
I don't know if it's
a little bit so it's a one minor problem
right so
right I mean in terms of argument
checking we have lots of Q functions
which are kind of the wrong thing for
this right like like if we had this we'd
want to have lots of canonicalizing
functions
like canonicalize this as a number
right
yeah I mean what do you mean you could
not guys pi squared over seven to be a
number
right I mean for example suppose that I
wanted to maybe numbers the wrong uh the
wrong example but I mean take take um
so right take like geoposition for for
example right you'd want to have a
function I think
we'd be more likely to have a
geoposition Q function than we'd be to
have a canonicalize this as a
geoposition take whatever form it is and
and zero position is a canonicalizer
itself
okay so I guess then you just put Geo
position comma and then the theoretical
geoposition Q would be the third
argument or something I'm just trying to
imagine because we have a lot of Q
functions right and we don't have a lot
of canonicalizing functions explicitly
okay but I think the reason for that is
because a lot of things that are
ultimately rappers like geoposition do
their canonicalization
right but they also do things like throw
messages when they fail
some of them do I mean this is date
object probably has a canonicalizing
functionality you know n has a
canonicalizing functionality in some
sense what else does
I bet this one's with URLs and things
like that
but the things like okay I need to take
a valid polygon or something
I mean I guess I guess I guess we do
actually have canonicalized polygons one
of the only canonicalized functions we
have
but if it fails it's also probably going
to fail dramatically as opposed to
returning a failure object or something
like that
could work from alpha with more from
result second argument be some sort of
default
what are you saying
more from alpha with string ball from
result a second argument
it's very powerful converting anything
into a into our language expression
so many of the geofunctions when they
don't know what to do they try this
there's also a semantic interpretation
which I don't know whether they're
different or whether they should be
different but with second argument uh
ball from result
that's disappointing
why wouldn't that work
but this is perhaps too complicated
about the five miles with
convert it into a quantity
okay
and this is the kind of thing I would
expect because I think that will work as
a as a
I mean I'm sure if I do
foreign
huh
and what it's worth also the semantic
interpretation fails on that so I wonder
if it's uh
that's really weird I thought those
worked
well that's a that's a wolf now for
parsing thing maybe Avery can can um
chase that
yeah
so back to the previous section did I
think we need a a blank colon in front
of those things because otherwise I
don't see how you'll ever be able to
restrict the pattern in a pattern-y sort
of way
sorry so you're trying to say like to
specify that it's not a sequence or
something
right or right or if you if you know if
you wanna
um
right if you want it to be
part of
a uh
um right how would you get the at right
how would you get the x is what I'm
saying I think the why yeah no the X to
which that
X colon in front of it pattern
um
wait a minute so you're saying
if I say that
what's wrong with that I mean it'll pick
up the raw undigested thing
that is whatever the canonicalizing
pattern was was operating on
right well suppose you want uh
maybe you only wanted it to match things
on X right
you might want
yeah because you might want to do that
to disambiguate different different
usages or something
Yeah
so basically we'd have well right so the
way that this would normally work with
patterns is you'd have an argument to
canonicalizing pattern that is that
defaults to blank
but by which you could set to underscore
integer or something like that
right
that's the input so in other words it
would be instead
and it's a little weird it would be this
what this is trying to match
what the canonicalized name is
and what the canonicalizer is that's a
little bit and then a test argument is
the test yeah
it might be worth putting the blank only
the third one is mandatory
yeah that's a little maybe maybe we need
to change the order if only the third
one is
where will we put the blank I mean I
think the blanks should go third because
the the most common case Okay the most
common the minimal case is you just give
the canonicalizing function as a test
the the next most common case is you
want to bind you know y to the
canonicalized thing and then it's only
rarely do you need to test or that you
need to set a blank
fair enough okay but then okay well we
should note here also taking a step back
all of these things we've been looking
at ignore the number two from above
because I don't think it'll be common
that it even exists
do we need to have support for that or
can we drop it fully what does the Y
bind to does it bind to the fully
digested form well I I don't know what
this partially digested formula yeah do
you you mean that yeah go ahead the
output of the fun
that binds to the output of fun
the idea of partial digestion only
exists if you have fun and you had some
other function that's like the you know
and I don't know what that would even
mean
like number two seems like an
implementation detail foreign
utterly random note you probably could
do it with nested calls to
canonicalizing patterns
where you could put the canonicalizing
pattern in the third argument where that
blank is you could put it I'll leave
that as an exercise for the reader yes
okay implementer or something okay all
right so let's go through this for a
second so what kinds of things do we
think
would actually be useful I mean again
we've got this cold question about what
the test does
etc et cetera et cetera
but
and in the world of restrictions
the second argument of this if I'm
remembering correctly for interpreter is
a restriction is that correct column
no it's not correct restriction isn't
the first argument because it's the
expected of location yeah the third the
second argument is test okay so so the
first argument works with the type
system the second argument is a
predicate
okay fine
fine that's fine okay so let's look at
some things that will be useful right so
I mean
the thing that isn't obvious to me
okay so let's take two cases one where
you really can say F of NYC
and the other where you're saying only
things that for you know because
geoposition of NYC doesn't work does it
I hope it doesn't
yeah
right
um
so
but then it's F of
Battle of Hastings
where it is presumably the case that
geoposition
of this
just works
right
giving its canonical form
so I'm drawing a distinction here
between you know one might want F can
accept anything which when wrapped with
geoposition but I think what what we're
saying here is then the way you write
this is f of canonicalizing pattern
of X comma
um
geoposition
right
that gets the second Behavior if you
want to support NYC then you should say
interpreter of location instead yep
foreign
go ahead
well I was just going to propose one
other example because because I'm trying
to think of sort of built-in existing
functions we have that you'd often put
in that second argument so another case
where I run into this is things with
regions we have a lot of different like
heads and things that represent regions
like you know discs scope and close is a
region and so is boundary mesh region
and so whatever what would you put
though
well I would like if it existed it would
be if maybe it does actually something
like a region queue which tells you
whether it's a disk or a boundary mesh
region key remember this isn't which
what you're putting there is the
canonicalizer not the Tesla right right
right
um
well I think that just works region of
disk works
I don't really understand what the thing
just called region does but but okay
that might be correct region tries to
visualize the thing
is it a valid region though like if you
said area a region of disk is that going
to work it goes One Direction if region
of something gives a picture it was a
valid region but there are valid region
we're reaching off something does not
work because you can encode uncomputed
regions properly in our language
right like some crazy implicit region
yeah something yeah
well okay so so there are questions
about what the canonicalizer names can
be here
and we can imagine supporting string
second arguments here that are various
kinds of things that have been currently
Subterranean objects
but okay let me just understand
semantics here the semantics are
this is the thing
which
if that canonicalization doesn't work
and by the way presumably okay
presumably if there is an error message
generated that message will be visible
when you say F of whatever
right I give a printed a message you
mean yes
but it's a little weird because the
message will be printed but then the
match will fail
that's true for pattern tests as well
though I don't think that's a major Fair
Point at that point right but this is
right I mean this is this is why I was
you know I think it's useful think about
what functions that we have support this
right because I think right you could
imagine that we could go out and
Implement a whole bunch of functions
just like we have a bunch of Q functions
and we have boundary mesh region Q we
could have a function that's sort of
purpose is to try and make something
into a boundary mesh region because you
know and maybe that function is because
right now the way we do that normally is
we just have it so boundary mesh region
tries to do that but but then if it
fails it usually fails catastrophically
and also in that particular case I think
boundary mesh region of disk doesn't
work I think you're supposed to say
boundary mesh of disk or something like
that so you know we're we're not very
consistent about this sort of
canonicalizer we think of it more of
like a Constructor than a canonicalizer
right
right so this might Force some thinking
about that but I'm I mean
you know I
I'm also
okay like here's another example let's
say
that I want to function where
well maybe maybe this just works where
the
okay I want a function where it's units
but the units represent money
right where I want that to be I can have
Euros I can have pounds I can have
whatever but I can't have meters
yeah
making sense
well you could you could always create a
if you do a unit convert I don't know
what unit convert does when you give it
meters until it just turned into Euros
complains
well you're saying how gracefully does
it completely we have the currency
interpreter right
sure we do right that's an interpreter
going from a string so we say unit
converter hash comma US dollars
um
right the question is though if it
doesn't match is it going to print
messages or something
right
and the answer is yes it prints a
message and then returns dollar failed
sander is commenting here on our live
stream
let's see would it create an interpreter
a bunch of times if you had 10 000 city
names
the answer is yes and the whole point is
we're trying to make that much faster
and you know we've had this long-running
project to have a local version of that
interpreter which I keep on hearing it's
almost ready
and hopefully by the next version it
really will be ready but maybe Avery you
could check into that let's say Charlie
Michaelson production
okay
um
well okay this this clearly requires
more thought but by the way there was
another
thing that Santa had sent through to us
about I think it was about Min of a
round or some thing like this which I
think got lost in some crazy interchange
it's on the LCC agenda for today okay
okay fine okay then good we have a art
together good stuff
well this is interesting this is not
something that have been on my radar to
think about this in a serious way I I
feel like this is not settled here but
at least we've got a beginning
um and maybe we could do a little bit
more thinking about this and bring this
back does that sound reasonable yeah
Sandra's question does bring up if
there's special handling of lists
because interpreter has special handling
of lists
that's well I mean the question of how
come true
especially handling of lists
it turns over lists
I mean you you can if you instead of
calling interpreter on a list you
collect on Alternatives it also does one
single API call it batches things
whenever you don't mind
it's interpreting the elements of the
list it's not interpreting the list
right yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
that's that's my point that's my point
through the listable but what I'm saying
is that if you do something super
complicated with compound Elementor
repeating element it will also collect
everything in one second but my point is
it interprets the elements in the list
so I wonder if this thing should do the
same thing and if the test function
should work on elements of the list or
on the list as a whole right yeah that's
a that's an open question right there's
two questions there's the question of of
efficiency is it going to make is it
going to consolidate calls and there's
the question of the thing we wrote
earlier of canonicalized pattern comma
interpreter of quotes location that will
accept a list right now
right
right so there are many detailed
questions here my feeling is this
canonicalizing pattern concept that
really basically it's going to end up
with a bunch of string second arguments
that are another family of kind of you
know categories of thing much like we
have an interpreter
rather than and maybe there is a Escape
Clause of you given explicit function
but my guess is that the useful stuff is
going to be a whole collection of
specific
you know categories of things I I I
disagree because the question is if we
were going to introduce a string
argument there like quotes boundary mesh
region or something like that why would
we not just make it a symbol and make it
an actual function that you can use in
other purposes yeah well Fair Point
third point but then that's then then
what we're talking about is a boatload
of new functions
right which possibly we should have but
I mean that's why that's why there's the
question of how it interacts with the
existing Constructors and with Q
functions and uh and what the convention
for such functions would be if if we
wanted to have them
right
well
I think let let us come come can this
get explored outside of this meeting and
come back and let's get a list of what
some interesting plausible canonicalizer
functions might be
yeah we can do an inventory and
right I mean I don't think it's going to
be huge I mean let's say there are five
of them then it's a perfectly reasonable
thing for us to expect to just introduce
those functions
if it's 25 then it's a more complicated
story
I mean we have like hundreds of Q
functions
yes
and here I mean we've got lots of types
of entities but I'm not sure that we
need you know there's a
there should be a generic version of
this for any type of entity that then
sub-specifies the type of entity I would
think sure sure
let's just take a look at roughly what
my gosh okay so we got guys this is a
combination of looking at our old design
notebook of things to migrate from Alpha
and some of the things we've learned
from Wolfram Alpha notebook Edition
um this was Michael provided a list
basically of things that
don't exist in Wolfram language or
aren't in the version of Welcome from
language that Alpha runs on that are
most frequently used in Wayne
right
um
well I think we've got several different
categories here we've got things that
are essentially math
area between curves complicity which we
now have
um but it probably isn't
I mean we have that in version 13 right
Michael
yep all right
but it's just that that's not the thing
that the cloud version is running right
for for Wayne
unfortunately
um
okay so we should break that early like
truth table that's Boolean table isn't
it
but maybe it's a beautified version It's
a beautified version
right
so how many of these can we break these
down into what is a beautifier what say
you know mathematical function
you know like like this is a beautifier
right I mean that would be like Factor
integer form of a of a list would be
some beautifier there yeah
um
let's break that down into beautifies
versus
actual functionality like diagonalized
Matrix sounds like functionality
is it uh it's kind of um some version of
Jordan decompositions
but is it something for which we could
have a function that does it or no I
think this one is probably more
specialized to the audience
I mean I don't know what this returns
but right I mean this is either some
version of eigen system or Jordan
decomposition correct
and I think it's the letter
okay
I mean some of these like area between
curves
I mean
at the level of language why isn't there
just one integral minus the other or am
I confused
well um if it's smart and it does
you know it actually figures out you
know does the absolute value and figures
out which is higher
then you know it isn't
well it probably is smart that way
it figures out the intersections
in a in a symbolic way yeah
so fine so that's a possible function
that is a and what it will be called or
what you know whatever but that's a
possible I mean we could imagine you
know area between curves which right now
is a function repository function right
yeah
all of these are wfos yeah
which makes you know which is possibly
where they should be
um
yeah yes I know like the interactive
Factor inductor is not situated because
it isn't really a function that does
something it's more like a star form so
we don't have a good functionality to
just display something and then use it
as the same thing like it's still the
integral
I see
but but wait a minute it's it's in an
active form
so I mean we do have a way to display an
activated forms
yes but then if you use it you would
have to activate it and how to activate
like it says show me the factorization
now it's clear you don't want the
exponents clear up you want 12 squared
well okay but you're asking for
something that we don't have a real
mechanism in the language to do I mean
it's either Matrix form is not too
different
yeah but that that only works Matrix
form only works on an output line
no I think this has been fixed it works
no better
no the behavior hasn't changed
the
I mean if I say patient has been
improved but the behavior hasn't changed
if I say this
I'm still going to be cooked if I say
this
yep
but that isn't what you think it is
no I meant kind of like the metrics
itself then Matrix form and then percent
squared oh sure this works because it
has slash slash Matrix form there
and then and therefore it it Burrows
it is that that slash Matrix form is
representing the fact that it's going to
burrow
but but the same could be done for the
factorization absolutely which is why
the first thing I said was what you want
is a factor integer form that's what
yeah that's what I'm saying the whole
time so no no they're both saying the
same thing for which there's already a
ticket somewhere it just you know
requires effort right so so that's I
mean okay so each of these has some
story like that
so it's going to take us a while to go
through these
uh well I I don't know that I agree that
each of them I mean like but they may
not all be they may not all make it okay
but but each one has a story about what
it should be doing
wow what's a traded log what does the
trade log mean you take look unto uh you
get complex
like to like it's like it's um some
naive version of inverse are commands
what the hell do people use that for uh
for a very large complexity classes
well it's a lovely function but but I
mean so let me understand it so you go
until it is the last
logging
before the thing goes negative
yeah
but don't you need to know how many
loggings you've done
no does it
it's many you did
what's is there is there a wfr function
for it
don't remember
I didn't see one but so what is its
return value
an integer
I see so it is telling you how many
times it has logged
oh I see so it's the inverse of 2 to the
two to the 2 to the it's inverse
titration in some sense there is a wfr
oh yeah you're right yeah that's what
I've said yeah
um
sounds like a worthwhile function to
have
um
yeah I mean I I think this seems like a
fine function
is that the
iterated log is a really weird name for
that is that what it's always called
I mean I'm confused because
in no sense it is is it the iterated log
it is the cardinality of logs
you know you get what I'm saying yeah
that's a nice function
and the default is e
the base
of the iterated logs
is that right yes
well it seems like a fine function but
anyway we should probably
um
and what does logit do
that's not what you do
another fine semen function
I mean this is used
how is this used in in I mean this is
used in a bunch of Statistics things
isn't it
I think so
anybody know here
I mean both of these functions seem like
things that we should build in I don't
see any reason not to
anybody
having no objection on my part
I mean
if it's just something that evaluates
away then
I don't see any value in it well except
for the fact that you're writing code
and you want to show what's going on in
the code and that has very high value
uh
yes but it has no value as as sort of a
built-in function I mean you could yes
it does
right you could write your own right I
mean this is this is but you're not
going to that's the whole thing not even
a one-line function this is uh I'm well
aware that's one of the things we've
learned over the last God knows how many
years that's what I used to think
exactly what you just said
no Stephen but but then people
complained well you know it doesn't get
this special value right and you can't
do and and you can't do this series
right because it evaluates away
right well the evaluating away thing
yes there are complaints about that in
certain cases
however the value of having something
which like you know it's a logit
function and you just want to put that
function in
you know it's really worthwhile to just
have that function not to go look up the
definition and so I mean it just doesn't
make sense
okay anyway this is probably going to be
a longer discussion let's just see what
roughly we have here
um
I don't know what the Luck's going to be
was digit get
this is especially people asked for a
ridiculous like the the Google's number
of three-fifths or something like this
they are you have no chance to to do it
is it it's especially this end
fractional digit that
don't we haven't did it at this point
I thought we had enter digit did we not
put that in
I think we renamed it but I don't
remember what the new name was
we published a resource function for it
from the math team on Wolfram Alpha but
I don't think it's
I think we definitely had long
discussions and
it's about a bit frustrating that none
of us know it's night
I think it's the number of digit
all right
yep
okay and what's the difference between
that and digit get
anybody discussed whether the number
represented
the count from the first digit or the
count from
from the first position with respect
we've got a definite function here my
question is what's the difference
between that and the proposed digit get
I mean I don't think there is one okay
so that's just a mistake I mean it's
that's interesting
I think we should consider these
sorry I'm just starting this number
digit but
it doesn't really work for large numbers
which is what people put into Alpha okay
fine fine fine that's a different issue
yeah that's the reason to get it to work
properly yes
and what should it do in those I I see
in the case where it's a a rational for
example then it knows what to do exactly
okay so that's just an implementation
yes thing the number digit yeah and if
you've already got a way to do that
let's feed that into yeah
you know Nick or whoever else is dealing
with number digit
that seems like an easy thing to take
care of
all right I think we've got other things
then to cover another time I I
personally I'm I'm I I kind of believe
in the sign degree thing
I think we've we've added some functions
like that and they have been a good idea
um
anybody wants to comment on that
immediately
yeah I think the main concern was just
like how far we go with it and you know
do we have a degree version of all the
trig functions
right so that's not one function that's
12 functions yeah yep and
um
yep
uh you have a rotate degree
oh I hope not yeah I hope not as well
well you can transform degree or
whatever
yeah that's crazy angle Vector degree
all right okay okay okay okay
um
right
maybe well I'll do a more thorough
inventory and just kind of try and come
up with classes and we can look at it in
a little more detail but
I I would argue it's it's it is a good
thing that every single function that
expects an angle expects radians you
know you know if you want something else
you know just just as in in you know Geo
range and and NGO functions everything
expects meters if you give it an integer
and if you want something other than
meters you use a quantity
that's a reasonable argument for this
all right we should wrap up here and um
uh some of you are involved and also in
the design review that's coming up in a
couple of hours
um
all right thanks a lot see you later